ich schwöre vor ist ich will kein bock
hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen beim
neuen video
ich hab mal wieder die caro dabei auf
jeden fall wir haben uns gedacht also
der mir letztens sondern folge dreht
dinge die sie jemals zu deiner freunde
sagen sollte und das gar nicht gut
angekommen also ich glaube dass gut
angekommen ja es war gut und da wir uns
gedacht lass einfach noch einen zweiten
teil machen und vielleicht auch im
dritten teil
ja das gibt's heute wir wollen wir nicht
anfangen direkt mal an was gefällt und
wir noch im dritten teil sehen wollt
dann das jetzt daumen nach oben da wir
fangen direkt mal an aber ich bin ganz
gut gelaunt ich nicht schlimm ich könnte
mal lachen okay wir fangen erst mal mit
was nicht so obwohl das ist schon
schlimm war's eigentlich immer schon
hässlich oder bin ich einfach hübsch
geworden
endlich weiß nicht ich finde habe ich
erst schlimmer dass du sagst bin ich
geworden
ich habe jetzt meine arbeit gelb gefärbt
willst du das geld eigentlich ganz ganz
ehrlich stell dir vor ich hab jetzt ein
dickes telefonbuch und wenn man in der
mitte ein paar seiten raus heißt fällt
doch auch so gut als das gelesen
kreativ das cradle fußangel ich habe
mich auch ins tram so gesagt ja sagt ein
paar dinge die man niemals zu seiner
feine sagen sollte dann habt ihr das
geschrieben waren so danke nochmal an
dieser stelle machen weiter also ich hab
mir auch die haare so gefährden und
meine lieblingsfarbe ist halt geld
kannst mal lächeln danke also viele
leute sagen ja dass mcdonald's so
menschen formen und du bist das beste
beispiel habe ich nicht das ist ja nun
sitzt jetzt so viel ich keine ahnung
gestern habe ich das vergessen und
burger king davor einen tag habe ich ein
mcdonald s und davor den tag habe ich
pizza gegessen
ich stelle immer so auch um 14 uhr und
dann esse ich nichts und angst und halt
immer ungesund
willst du meine sonne sein
dann geh doch einfach 99 millionen
800.000 37 weg ein video das finde ich
weil er gar nicht geguckt boschert kann
ich nur jedem bild von dir machen
gut das kann ich perfekt nehmen weil wir
müssen in bio seinem referat über
naturkatastrophen und pkw anklicken kann
viele leute werde überlegt wir machen
das auch mal umgekehrt und ich kann sehr
schlecht schlagende als schlag ins
begrüßungs schlages ihm aber wir haben
uns gedacht wir machen das einfach so
ich kaufe so zehn kuchen und immer wenn
ich etwas schimpfen da habe ich jetzt
einen kuchen ins gesicht ist das gut
schreibt zwar in die kommentare
jetzt nur mit was ist das war das ist
dann war es das ist doch jetzt war okay
leute das wollen jetzt schon wieder ein
paar harte sachen dabei gehört erst mal
sagen das war's an dieser stelle ich
habe eben schon gesagt ein teil 3 drehen
wir uns wahrscheinlich gleich auch noch
fordern so dann kommt er halt nächste
woche sonntag genau da kommt der nächste
woche sonntag allein deswegen wenn ihr
da auch bock drauf habe dann lasst auf
jeden fall nach oben da und jetzt stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp nicht
wegschalten und zwar die karte auch
sofort oder der oder das karl may
treuhand hatte auch bock auf dem youtube
channel
die hat sich auf jeden fall auch ein
gemacht und da ist heute auch ein video
also genau jetzt mal das video online
kommt es auch ein video online gegangen
bist du da jetzt muss zu sein
ja ich könnte mal weich machen fahren
einfach so aus die sitzt da das war also
schaute vorbei der link ist in der video
beschreibung abonniert sie wenn ihr
wollt und so höhere abonniert thema
vielleicht direkt von 13 abonnenten
nein ich freue mich über jeden einzelnen
kunden auf jeden fall jugend links geht
weiter mit der letzten folge das haben
wir also die erste folge ist hier
verlinkt auch in der video beschreibung
passt auf jeden fall noch abwenden ist
noch nicht gesehen hab mich könnt ihr
auf länderebene audio nicken und mit den
uns dann am nächsten mittwoch wieder
hunderte auf